all right now we're sitting down with
Paul Blum from neuro Karis also at Indy
bio demoed a batch number six this is
awesome biotech so amazing I'm so
grateful I love it here
I love it yeah I love it so all right
Paul was just teaching us about neuro
Kerris which is working on a proprietary
molecule that inhibits pain directly in
the location that it's applied that's
correct so teach us about this right so
pain is something that happens in the
periphery of your body it doesn't happen
in your brain in fact when people have
brain surgery the brain itself doesn't
experience any pain it's all on the
periphery of your body and it's because
of the presence in your body of what are
called sensory neurons all you could
call them pain neurons but they're all
outside of the brain and they are what
has the sensation they transmit a signal
to your brain your brain goes oh that's
pain and it typically responds by
sending a single back down to the same
location through a different neuron
called a motor neuron that triggers a
muscle and the muscle makes you jerk
your hand or your knee away from
whatever was hurting you okay hold
that's called the plane the pain circuit
so that paints are good let's just do
that one more time
so we have a sensory neuron yes that
goes and then that goes back to the
motor room through a motor neuron to a
muscle and the muscle helps you get away
from the pain the pain whoa so that all
happens in a millisecond that's right
super fast holy cow okay and so what
opioids do just in contrast not our drug
but opioids is they act systemically
they're not targeted you take a pill
like oxycontin dissolves in your stomach
enters your bloodstream all the tissues
in your body are exposed to this drug in
any tissue that has an opioid receptor
response to the drug and that's fine if
it's a pain neuron problem is if you
have pleasure centers in your brain and
when they respond you get addicted to
the euphoria and it was the breathing
center in your brain you stopped
breathing which is why people die when
the overdose they suffocate okay that's
the side effect of an untargeted drug so
our drug is targeted and to some part
targeted because we administered by
injection you don't take it as a pill
but also because there's no reason to
treat your brain you don't need to train
you you want to treat the pain
the pain is located peripherally it's
located whatever you did to yourself or
if it's some sort of degenerative
disease you want to treat that point
okay so it's but the goal is to stop the
generation of the pain signal so it's
like an electric wire and you just cut
the wire and so that's essentially what
we're doing though it's not permanent so
far our studies our drug is reversible
so it lasts or about four days and then
it wears off which opiate lasts for one
day we're hoping to try to extend the
duration but the important thing is
because it wears off it means the drug
is reversible yes which means there's no
permanent effect on these sensory
neurons so has to be they must come back
to life because if you've got the pain
again right so so that's important it
will feel again yes absolutely you want
to retain sensation yeah so basically
that's how holy cow okay so it's a
rational approach to pain control now
why do we use opioids how comes so much
pain control water we have an epidemic
it's because pain wasn't even recognized
as a problem in human in the 1960s you
go to the dentist you'd get yourself a
tooth told and if you were a child they
didn't give you any pain control because
children weren't supposed to feel pain
according to the American children's
what's the call the American pediatric
society okay and then by the mid 70s
late 70s pain started to be recognized
as a vital sign in the US medical system
and doctors were allowed to ask how you
felt and then treat the pain and what
was available at that time was historic
pain control drugs opioids or other
related drugs and then though it was
fine people started taking opioids and
then the drug companies came out with
longer acting opioids which were claimed
to be non addictive and it turned out
that was wrong and as a consequence we
ended up with opioid epidemic so why do
we use these drugs are historic
you know 5000 years of pain control with
these plant drugs they're not engineered
drugs they're not rationally designed
drugs they're not targeted drugs and now
we're targeting exactly where the pain
is that's any we're injecting that's
right so so and we're also working on a
top
so a cream Oh in fact so our druggist is
being has already now been recognized by
one of the National Institutes of Health
of which there are 23 US federal
agencies charged with biomedical
research and this one is on drug abuse
it's called the National Institutes of
Drug Abuse and they have recognized our
drug because of its potential to fight
the opioid epidemic and they want us to
do the topical and right now is it quite
expensive to get well our drug is not in
manufacturing we are in what's called
preclinical development you're still pre
we know how to make the thing we know
how to test it in animals it works great
stops pain and animals we have not
tested it on people yet yeah that's why
we're raising money we're trying to get
into clinical trials of humans now how
is this molecule even developed how did
we figure it out we created it it's by
protein engineering so my partner Ben
Pavlik and I have 30 years of protein
engineering experience and we came up
with it in a rational design type of an
approach we said Century neurons are the
target how do you target them Oh take
proteins modify them and then this is a
multifunctional protein it doesn't just
bind these unique neurons it actually
goes inside of them and inside of the
mid targets a structure called the axon
which is what connects the nerve to your
brain and then it targets the specific
protein inside of there called actin and
it destabilizes the actin and when that
happens you cut the wire so there's no
more transmission of the pain signals so
that all requires three functions in
this engineered protein Wow so it's a
complex protein ok so then the molecule
is a protein yours that's correct it's
biological we call it in a biological
protein an engineered protein and then
it goes into the neuron the sensory
nerve into it binds to the outside
uniquely doesn't bind motor neuron so
only binds sensor nuts goes inside and
then it releases that's actually a big
step what's called a therapeutic payload
and that payload is another protein that
modifies this protein called actin an
actin is what makes up the cytoskeleton
which is the structure that gives you
that long finger like projections which
is what connects the neuron do your
brain so now you can have a sensory
neuron on your finger it has an axon it
goes all the way down your arm all the
way to your spinal column
that long structure requires a little
skeleton and that's the actin you change
the structure of that skeleton you
blocked it pain transmission that's so
awful but it happens over here yeah as
you're putting it on the tip of your
finger and hopefully you can just be
topological so that's what we would like
yeah and they'll arts needle some about
how much of the neuro cares do you need
how much of the drug well right now
we're one fifth of what's called one
fifth of molar dose of an opiate
so in our animal drug trials we compete
against opiates and so we're talking
about using animals doing behavior
studies we're doing paint outs okay so
we compete against opiates and both are
injected and the amount that we inject
is one-fifth the amount of the OPA so we
know it's more potent yeah one way to
answer that's good that's good and you
also know it's longer-acting amazing
this has tremendous potential in the
world tremendous I'm super excited about
absolutely and it's that's what's odd is
that there hasn't been much innovation
in pain control and that's there's a
reason the reason is because it's not
recognized as a disease where the u.s.
in particular has put so much research
money into it's always about diseases
pain is a symptom and so it's not
formally addressed in our current
funding mechanism in the United States
so it's unfortunate and it's also
unfortunate because we have this other
stuff called opioids and there's a whole
incumbent market for that Oh highly
developed geopolitical it's complicated
and it's good I'm happy that you guys
are tackling this is there something
else about neuro carrots that we should
know we're startup company
we're looking for investors or trying to
get in I would complete our what are
called preclinical development efforts
and get into clinical trials and we're
targeting osteoarthritis that's our
primary indication so that's mostly for
people with back pain lower back pain or
knees sometimes it's shoulder finger
joints you know and that's our primary
goal because the type of treatment
options for those things aren't good
so there's not even you know you can
take opioids but they're oftentimes not
effective for strong back pain or a
strong joint pain because for all sorts
of reasons sometimes people are allergic
sometimes they become addicted sometimes
and doctors are now being regulated so
they can't prescribe as much because of
the addiction problems so those that's
what we're talking I think that's that's
probably yep you know Paul this is such
a pleasure thank you for thank you you
and Ben yes grant a book yeah thank you
so much for watching this has been a
blast thank you and I'll send you a
message great appreciate it okay thanks
a lot